CHARLIE: So my name
is Charlie [? Lai, ?]
and this is my
colleague Alex Garcia.
We're part of the Google
Bay Area Farm To Table Group
here at Google.
And our mission is to
promote events and ideas
related to food sustainability.
And that is why we're
very excited today
to have two very special guests,
Curt Ellis and Sara Ting,
who Alex will now introduce.
ALEX GARCIA: Thank you.
Curt is the CEO and co-founder
of Food Corps, a fast growing
national nonprofit.
Food Corps' mission is working
together with communities
to connect kids to
healthy food in school.
Joining Curt on stage
today is Sarah Ting,
who is an alumni of
the Food Corps program.
So with that, I want to welcome
Curt and Sarah to tell us
a little bit more about it.
[APPLAUSE]
CURT ELLIS: Fantastic.
Thank you all so much
for coming today.
And a huge thanks to Charlie,
and Alex, and my old friend
[? Krista Essig ?],
who's been involved
in Food Corps since
the earliest days,
for hosting us
through Google Food.
I'd like to start by sharing
a little bit of the story that
brought me here today.
If you go back to the year
that I graduated from college,
I remember our classmates
setting out for Wall Street
and for Silicon
Valley, and the feeling
that my best friend
and I had of wanting
to go somewhere different.
The path we took was a
little less than a path.
It was more like
I-80, and we followed
it all the way to
Iowa with our goods
packed in the back
of a pickup truck
until we reached a curmudgeonly
farmer's house in rural Floyd
County and convinced him to
lease us one acre of land
on which we could grow
food in the blackest dirt
that I had ever seen.
Like any good Iowa corn farmer,
we planted our field in corn.
And like any good member
of our generation,
we followed the
cardinal rule of pics
or it didn't really happen.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-It's America's
best kept secret.
We don't think of what we're
putting into our system.
We don't really think about it.
-Pork.
-Beef.
-Bread.
-Soda.
-Chicken.
-French fries.
-Spaghetti sauces.
-Biscuits with gravy.
-Everything on
your plate is corn.
GEORGE W. BUSH: When
you're good at somethin',
we ought to be encouraging it.
We're good at growing corn,
and we're now selling it
all around the world.
[CHEERING]
-What is is this here?
-That's excess corn.
-That's what couldn't
fit in that huge thing.
-That's right.
-Huh.
-I'm movin' from Boston to Iowa.
-Could I have a Big
and Tasty sandwich?
-I used to weigh
over 300 pounds.
-Lot's of corn means
the raw material
for an overweight society.
-Hello, carbs.
-All that corn goes somewhere,
and in fact a lot of it's
going onto our bodies.
-We aren't growing quality.
We're growing crap.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
CURT ELLIS: Now in
retrospect we could
have made this film
infinitely shorter
than we actually made
it, because it turns out
that somebody else had
already told the same story we
were trying to tell.
It was Steve Martin
who, back in the 1970s,
used to do stand up comedy.
And he had a bit where
he would conjecture
that maybe everything that
actually shows up in McDonald's
is made out of the same stuff.
And if you could go
into the back room
and peel back the
door on the kitchen,
you would see this
conveyor belt going
by with these
different molds on it.
And you would see this
vat full of this stuff,
and there would be the
cook going [SLAPPING SOUND]
hamburger, [SLAPPING SOUND]
French fries, [SLAPPING SOUND]
paper box.
And of course what Steve didn't
really realize at the time
is that's actually true.
The hamburger in the typical
fast food meal is corn fed.
The soda in the
typical fast food soda
is sweetened with an incredible
amount of high fructose corn
syrup.
And the French fries are
quite often fried in corn oil.
And pleasingly, even
the box now typically
has a corn based
wax on the coating.
That acre of land that my best
friend and I grew in the year
after college was
not a very big plot.
I mean, it's about the
size of a football field.
But just that one acre
produced 10,000 pounds
of corn, five tons of food.
And that is enough to raise
4,000 corn fed hamburgers,
or enough to sweeten
57,000 cans of soda
with high fructose corn syrup.
We grew just one acre, but
America's farmers on the whole
grow 94 million acres
of corn each year,
harvesting 14 billion
bushels of grain.
Agricultural economists track
where all of that harvest
ends up using a term
called corn disappearance.
But the reality, if you look
around America these days,
is that that corn isn't
really disappearing.
We're each carrying a
significant portion of it
with us every single day.
The reality is that
half of all Americans
are overweight or obese,
and diet related disease
like type 2 diabetes
is affecting
kids younger and younger.
The government's own
estimate is that by 2030,
when the current obesity
generation is all grown up,
we will face a $1 trillion
annual economic cost related
to diet related disease.
Half of that comes in the
form of direct obesity related
medical costs.
And the other half of
it comes in the form
of lost economic productivity.
And I want to pause on that
lost economic productivity
for a moment, because it sounds
like it's sort of a throw away.
But $500 billion a year
is not monopoly money.
And it's not actually
money that matters.
It is the broken
dreams of people
who attain less education,
advance less in their careers,
are out sick more at
work, and raise families
who themselves are at elevated
risk of diet related disease.
That lost economic productivity
is real people missing out
on social mobility.
Obesity is fuel for the
relentless cycle of poverty,
and poverty is fuel for the
relentless cycle of obesity.
Diet related disease
in all of its forms
deepens the systemic
inequities that
already hold our country back.
And it doesn't just
discriminate by income.
Half of all kids of
color are expected
to develop type 2 diabetes
during their lifetime, a rate
50% higher than white children.
In the decades that we
have been incentivizing
corn production in this country,
brewing high fructose corn
syrup in our factories,
and raising corn fed
meat on our farms,
we've developed
a powerful and now deeply
ingrained set of food habits,
most of them revolving
around a culture
of refined grains, added fats,
and added sugars, processed
food, and empty calories.
Corn in the way we grow,
and process, and consume it,
looks very little like
a vegetable today.
Those eating habits get
set incredibly young,
and they shape us both
figuratively and quite
literally throughout
the rest of our lives.
I remember the night that
we were preparing to harvest
our corn in the morning.
We decided to lay
out sleeping bags
between the rows
in our cornfield
and sleep out under the stars.
Our year had passed.
My best friend and I had
had a grand adventure
in the heartland.
But ultimately, we
were left feeling
like we had done little good.
The film we had made
was going to go off
to movie theaters that would
show it alongside 72 ounce
sodas that people in the
audience would be drinking.
We wanted, on some level,
a chance at a do-over.
We wanted to know what we
could have accomplished
if we had spent our year
after college not reinforcing
America's broken food happens,
but helping to set new ones.
Not long after, I
started traveling around
to college campuses, and giving
talks, and showing our film.
And I was amazed with
the number of students
who would show up and break with
their 21-year-old busy routine
of drinking beer and writing
code to come out and watch
a corn film.
First I realized
they were probably
thinking they were going
to see a porn film,
and they were disappointed
when they got there.
But then ultimately I
understood why they had come.
Food is a prism, and
people in this generation
recognize what a powerful
story food has to tell us.
When you peer into
that prism of food,
you see our nation's greatest
challenges refracted.
You see human health.
You see environmental
sustainability.
You see the cultural shift
away from the dinner table.
You see issues of social
justice and racial justice
in terms of who has
access to healthy food.
And you realize
that maybe somehow,
if we could address
these issues in our food,
that simple fundamental thing
we put in our bodies every day,
we might begin to
see a roadmap for how
we could address those same
things across our society.
Meeting those students
and hearing their passion
for creating a more just, and
healthful, and sustainable food
system, we realized that the
do-over we were hoping to have
could be had not by us, because
we couldn't go back in time,
but by other people who
wanted to go forward.
So with a group of friends,
we launched a nonprofit
that we called Food Corps.
Food Corps is a nationwide team
of leaders who connect kids
to healthy food in school.
Our core members
dedicate themselves
to a year or two of
AmeriCorps service,
working hand-in-hand with
community partners across 18
states, and hundreds
and hundreds of schools,
to make those
schools fundamentally
healthier places for kids to
eat, and learn, and grow up in.
We have Corps members
from Maine to Mississippi,
from California to,
yes, Iowa, where
we have a team just a few miles
from that acre of corn, doing
simple good work
day in and day out,
helping kids fall in love
with fruits and vegetables
and set new eating
habits in place.
Our sixth class of Food Corps
service members is in the field
now, 215 passionate
and talented people
selected from about
1,000 who applied.
Most of them recently wrapped
up college or grad school,
but a number of them
were non-college bound
or have returned to
service as grandparents.
The majority of
our Corps members
are serving in their home state.
Many of them are serving
in their home communities.
And some are serving in the
various schools they themselves
attended.
I'm honored to introduce
you to a Food Corps alum
today, Sarah Ting.
Sarah served in her
hometown of Oakland
where she built school gardens.
She taught nutrition lessons
to 16 classes a week.
And she surveyed and analyzed
145 different California
farmers who were supplying
food to Oakland unified schools
to figure out how
we could scale up
the connection between
school children's lunch trays
and those local
farms and farmers.
Visiting Sarah in her schools,
it was apparent every time
just how dedicated she was
to the service she was doing.
Sarah, what brought
you to Food Corps.
SARAH TING: Thank you, Curt.
Yeah, so leading
up into this year
that I served in Food
Corps, I actually
had a similar experience being
out in agricultural fields,
in the food system, exploring
what it meant right now to be
a part of a food system.
But I wasn't a part of my
home community food system
at the time.
I actually was far
away in India working
with a trade union
of women who were
all a part of a collective
of informal workers.
And many of them
were in agriculture.
Some were contract
farm laborers,
and some were street vendors.
But what I witnessed
there was that there
was this amazing power in the
collective they had formed
and that, despite the
fact that they had faced
enormous struggle, and
most of the society
they lived in and did
not consider them to have
much power, they came together
to work on the issues that
mattered to them and form
new food systems that
nourished their communities.
And so that really
inspired me to want
to go home to join an
organization that I
could really do the same
in my own home community.
So I came back to Oakland,
and I found Food Corps.
And in that service,
I really wanted
to know what were sort of the
historical contexts for food
in my community.
And when I think of that, I
think of the Black Panther
Party.
And many of you might
know the Black Panther
Party is from Oakland.
But you may not know
that they actually
had a lot of service programs in
the community, and one of them
being a school breakfast
program for kids.
And so in the
midst of the 1960s,
there were a lot of school food
programs that were rolling out.
There were still black
children in Oakland
that were going hungry.
And so the Black
Panther Party served
thousands of school
breakfasts every day
to serve the community.
And I think that's a great
reminder, in this context,
working with food inequities,
that there's-- like the women
in India-- that there is
always this strong leadership
and power in community.
And in that context, I went
into my Food Corps service
really wanting to
know how can we
work and be inclusive
of communities
and their leadership and work
towards a more equitable system
with that.
And I found that
partner in Ford Corps
and in Oakland Unified
School District,
and figuring out
how we could really
apply that on the ground.
CURT ELLIS: Awesome
Food Corps believes
that, if we are going to be
successful at driving change,
it's going to be that we were
not the ones who ultimately
drove it.
Solutions need to be co-created
with the communities we're
serving, or else they
will have no relevance
to those communities.
Food Corps needs to look
different in the Mississippi
Delta from how it looks in
Detroit, from how it looks
in Hawaii, to how it looks in
rural Maine, or rural Montana,
or rural Iowa.
But underneath the
difference that
makes our country
special and the need
to adapt our programming
to match its place,
the reality is that there
are also some foundations
of evidence that hold true.
There are some
strategies that are
known to be effective
at connecting kids
to healthy food in school.
And if you can adapt
those strategies to match
the cultural context and
the climate in which you're
working, then you can
really unlock impact.
Food Corps has worked with a
team of researchers at Columbia
to develop a framework for our
work planning and our impact
tracking school
by school that is
all about finding those things
that the evidence shows truly
move the needle on kids eating
more fruits and vegetables
and putting those building
blocks in place to create
a healthy school
food environment.
There are things I
wanted to share with you
today, because there are
things you can replicate
in your children's schools.
And there are things in many
ways you can replicate at home.
The first one is that the
research makes it very clear
that, if you want a child to
fall in love with healthy food
and to begin to choose
it, you start by getting
their hands in the dirt.
For too long, we've
treated nutrition education
as something where
somebody points
at a poster on the wall
for about 3.4 hours a year
in the case of a typical
elementary schooler's
education.
And we expect some
good to come of that.
It doesn't actually work.
What works is getting
kids the chance
to smell the leaves
of a tomato plant,
to pull carrots
out of the ground
and taste them with
the dirt still on,
and to have the sense
of joy, and pride,
and ownership that
comes from creating
their own plate of food.
Researchers will tell you
that kids who have a garden
eat on average one more
serving of fruit and vegetables
than their peers each day.
Kids will tell you
something different, which
is that gardens are magic.
As one student told us, I want
to rename our garden the Golden
Garden.
Because when I think of that
garden, everything I see
turns to gold.
Cooking with kids
can be magic, too.
As we heard from a Corps member
of ours in New Jersey recently,
dang Miss Rachel,
this Collard pesto
tastes better than
cheeseburgers.
The research also shows
that, even from a young age,
food should not just
be about sustenance.
It should be about values.
By connecting with one child's
commitment to environmentalism,
we heard from her recently that
worms are the only true rock
stars to me.
Most importantly, we need
to help kids get over
the fear of trying new things.
Neophobia is one of the greatest
concerns for researchers
in the nutrition science field.
And for all the effort we
put into helping kids develop
a growth mindset
in the classroom,
we fail to cultivate one
around the dinner table.
For Food Corps, we do
taste tests all the time,
where we introduce new foods,
not covering somebody's plate,
but just a little bit.
And we invite kids to vote
in three categories-- loved
it, liked it, or tried it.
I don't see any reason to
set the bar lower than that.
We know this kind of
hands-on discovery
really works for connecting
kids to healthy food,
because 7 out of 10 kids
taught in Food Corps
classes shift their attitudes
in a positive direction
about fruits and vegetables.
And the numbers
go off the charts
for the fruits and
vegetables they've really
focused on in their lessons.
Kids also try new
food in Food Corps.
And it takes an
incredible discipline
of trying new foods over,
and over, and over again
before you may crack through
to that food being one
a kid truly loves.
The reality, though, is
that too many families
don't have the luxury
or the privilege
to do that trying, and
trying, and trying again,
because it means
throwing out the broccoli
that you've worked
so hard to buy.
That's why Food Corps focuses
our efforts on high needs
schools, places
where kids may not
have that opportunity at home,
and where we have an obligation
to make sure every
child has the chance
to try, and try, and
try new foods until they
learn they love them.
Sarah, what was your experience
with hands-on education?
SARAH TING: Yeah, I
really appreciate--
so I think this point
about an environment where
a kid's growing up
is really important.
What a child is exposed to, and
what their family is exposed
to, or the environment
that they're growing up in
can really shape
your food choices.
So in that way, there's
a sort of assumption
that we can all choose
to eat healthier.
But I think, while food is
a very personal thing-- it's
something that we associate
with love, family, culture,
our community--
like Curt has said,
it's also something that's
now very commoditized,
artificial, and
something highly marketed
to young kids, especially
black and brown kids
in communities like
mine in Oakland.
So when you come across
this intersection
where our food
becomes something that
leads to chronic diseases like
diabetes, and at the same time
leads to food insecurity
in my community,
there's this real
disconnect between children
and the personal and
cultural relationship
that they had to food.
So what I saw in the garden
was where we could really
make a space, an environment,
a safe green space
that kids could just be kids
and get their hands dirty.
And I saw this when we had
lessons where we planted
radish seeds into the ground.
And you could see the
wonder on children's faces
and see how a seed
could grow into a plant.
And for some of the
kids, that meant trying
a radish for the first time.
When we harvested them out of
the ground, they would say,
oh my gosh, what is
this, and then would
be able to try a brand new
veggie that they had never
been exposed to before.
And then for other students
who were very familiar
with radishes-- for
a lot of our students
with Mexican heritage--
they would say, rabanos?
Like, that's what my
mom puts in our pozole.
That's so cool.
I had no idea they
came from the ground.
And that way we could
make that connection
and solidify that personal and
cultural pride in the foods
that our kids were eating, and
know that healthy food came
straight from their homes.
So that was a really great way
that our garden could serve
so many different purposes.
CURT ELLIS: Awesome.
The second thing you
need to do, of course,
is figure out how
to move from kids
liking a taste of something
to actually eating
a plate full of it.
And once you've gotten
them interested,
that becomes possible.
There's a bunch of
really interesting
behavioral economics
research into how
you can shift food
choices and consumption
habits of kids who show up
in a school cafeteria or kids
who show up around your
family dinner table.
You can do things like give
kids a range of choices
so that they feel valued.
But make sure those choices
are all healthy choices.
These are basic design
thinking principles
you can start to bring to
how you re-imagine a school
cafeteria that in many ways
starts to respect children
as customers.
You can move the salad bar to
the front of the lunch line,
when kids show up with their
plates and lunch trays empty.
And you can move
the unhealthy food
to the back of the lunch
line, when those trays
are going to be full.
You can pause long
enough and observe
what's going on in the
lunchroom around you
to realize something that
shockingly few schools seem
to realize, which is that
kids in the second grade
have an incredibly hard
time biting into an apple,
because they're missing their
front teeth, and realize that,
if you cut up the
apple, suddenly
you could change the
behavior of the children
you're encouraging
to eat more fruit.
You also can't let junk food
companies be the ones who
have a monopoly on advertising.
I was talking to
somebody recently
who had worked for a large
processed food company
and had been in
meetings in that company
where they were
trying to hatch a plan
to increase the
lunchroom trading
value of one of the foods
they were marketing to kids.
And if we are not doing anything
on the healthy food side
to compete with that,
we are certainly
going to be left in the dust.
And the research is
clear that you actually
can have a huge impact just
with a simple change of naming
a menu item something
engaging and putting
a poster behind the salad bar
of a super hero eating spinach.
Suddenly kids' behavior
starts to shift.
Slogans like "eat the
rainbow" actually work.
And simple messages
like challenging kids
to cover half their plate
in fruits and vegetables
begin to move people
in the right direction.
Interestingly, the
research also shows
that kids are responding to
the same local food enthusiasm
that grownups are,
or it's possible
that actually both
of us are tapping
into something more innate.
The research is
clear that kids who
are told where a
food is coming from,
and have some reason to care
about the farm or the farmer
who brought it to them, eat
more of those healthy foods.
Ultimately though, one of the
most powerful things we can do
is put people in
school cafeterias who
serve as role models,
people like Sarah, who
make healthy eating
actually cool,
and who let their enthusiasm
catch on with kids.
And it doesn't just
Pretty soon idealism and a
sense of what is possible
catches on with food
service directors, too.
So far this year, Food
Corps service members
have introduced 600
new recipes or menu
items that are being served
at scale in schools and school
districts across the
country, showing just
how possible it is to
make this change actually
happen in a way that shifts
what arrives at a child's plate
at lunch.
Sarah, you did some cool
lunch work in your service.
What was that?
SARAH TING: Yeah, I think in
shifting the school menu, one
of them amazing things that we
did at Oakland Unified School
District was come in
with the assumption
that every single child has
a history with healthy food,
that whether it was the last
generation or their ancestors,
every single kid comes
from a culture that has
healthy food at their roots.
So what we did with the
Nutrition Services director
Jennifer [? Lebar, ?] and the
Farm To School supervisor Alex
Emmett-- they came together to
think about what are the ways
that we can help the
community drive this process,
to drive the taste
buds and the flavors
that we're going to be
trying to appeal to.
And so we did this in a
couple ways in Oakland.
The first was to
crowdsource the recipes
for reforming the school lunch.
And that was reaching out to
families, to students, to folks
in the community to see what
are the recipes that you already
have in your kitchens that
have healthy food in them.
And then what we could do
is kind of work backwards
and source those recipes
from local, sustainable, fair
sources.
And then second, once
we had those recipes
and were developing
them, we collaborated
with a community organization
that had youth leaders do peer
to peer taste tests so that the
youth could decide what they
wanted on the school menu, which
is incredibly important given
that, in Oakland,
for many students
the school lunch is the
majority of calories they're
taking in on any given day.
So you really need these
kids to love the food, right?
And so in that way, we
were able to both shift
the menu so that it was
more fresh, and local,
and sustainable,
but also reflect
the diversity of healthy food
and what healthy food really
is.
It could be from a Mexican
dish or a Vietnamese dish,
but it really showed our
kids that healthy food
comes from their roots.
And it's not
something necessarily
new to their culture.
CURT ELLIS: Awesome.
The last body of work
that Food Corps focuses on
in our efforts in schools around
the country, and that all of us
really can be focusing on in
our communities and our schools,
is around creating
a culture of health.
It's the difference, I
think, between attending
a foreign language
class once a week
and actually moving
to a foreign country
and immersing yourself
in a place and a people.
Those 3.4 hours of
nutrition education
we give a kid, if that's how
their nutrition education is
bucketed, it will
never have an impact
able to overcome the
same 3.4 hours of TV
that they watch
every single evening.
It has to be an
immersive experience.
In schools, creating
a culture of health
means not having healthy food
be one person's responsibility.
It means you have to catalyze
interest from all corners.
There's nothing more
demoralizing than giving
an amazing lesson in the
garden and then returning
to the classroom and finding
the teacher behind their desk
with a giant soda in
their hands getting
ready to throw candy to kids
who answer questions correctly.
The culture of health
has to transcend
the borders of the classroom
or the cafeteria as well.
It needs to echo
through the halls.
There needs to be signage.
There need to not
be vending machines.
You should see "let
us turn up the beat"
badges on kids' backpacks.
And ultimately, getting this
level of buy in means that
creating a culture of health
cannot be the work of one
person, either.
It has to be the work of a team.
And Food Corps, in
every school we serve,
now forms a school team at
the beginning of each year,
pulls in community
members, sometimes
kids, a particularly engaged
parent, a food service
director, and works together
to co-create our vision
for what that healthy
school needs to look
like by the end of the year.
Suddenly that small team
has a leadership role.
They've got goals
for themselves.
And by the time they get
to the end of the year,
they're already setting
their sights higher
for the following fall.
The results of
that kind of work,
where you build a small team,
and then you carry the work out
to a far larger school
and community culture,
means suddenly you
create momentum.
You create a culture that
people want to be a part of.
I think that's why Food
Corps now has 7,000 community
volunteers around
the country who
are joining us side
by side, Corps members
like Sarah, to put in
place those building
blocks of a healthy
food environment.
And they're doing it in a
way that's going to stick.
They're doing it in a way that
will truly have staying power
for the long term.
SARAH TING: Yeah, I think that's
an incredibly important piece
of the work, that we have to
include the whole community
in the process.
And that was true
for me, especially
in my community
of Oakland, and I
think true with other low
income communities of color
where folks have been
historically excluded
from safe spaces, healthy food,
from high quality education.
And so it comes as no
surprise when some folks feel
that they're just not-- don't
have a seat at the table
when it comes to something as
close to home as school lunch.
So when we think about ways that
we can build effective school
food programs that
are really going
to have a high impact
in the community,
I found that, when
we invited folks in,
when we let the
community lead, that's
where we found the results
that we were looking for.
That's when we we're shifting
and changing our food system.
And so I feel that
the work that we're
striving to do in Food
Corps, and the work
that we were doing in my
community in Oakland really
reflected that new
way of thinking,
of including all
folks at the table,
trying to have an inclusive
program and an inclusive system
where we could drive
to build institutions
that nourish all children.
CURT ELLIS: There's a way to do
this work that is deeply rooted
in the data of what actually
moves the needle on kids eating
fruits and vegetables, what
actually shifts food habits,
and to do it in a way that
is personal, and human,
and reflective of the
cultures we're serving.
Food Corps strives to strike
that balance of consistency
from place to place, to
build a proof point that
can be held up to policymakers
and others for replication,
while also ensuring that
our work is adapted enough
to the realities of
climate and culture,
that it truly has
relevance, and that it truly
lasts beyond the time any
one Corps member might serve.
Though the beauty of Food Corps
is that, every single year,
as each new class
comes on board,
there is one more
chance for a do-over.
There is a chance to do this
year's work better than last
year's.
We believe firmly that we have
to do that, because that's
the only way we go
from the 500 schools
Food Corps serves
today to the 100,000
schools across our country,
not with our program
scaling as some kind of
widget, but with people
around the country learning
what works, replicating it
in their own places, and us
getting smarter and better
every single time we try.
That's something we
believe firmly we
have an obligation to do.
Food Corps does not exist
to do small acts of charity.
We exist to solve the problem
of our nation's broken
food happens and to solve
that problem at the scale
at which it exists.
And that ultimately is a 100,000
school, 50 state challenge.
And we look to people like Sarah
and to partners like all of you
to make that work possible.
Because inside those
100,000 schools
are millions and
millions of children
who deserve to know
what healthy food is,
to care about where
it comes from,
and to eat it every single day.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-These are the next
generation of leaders
in food and agriculture.
These are the
people who are going
to make sure all
Americans have access
to healthy, fair,
affordable food grown
in a responsible,
sustainable way.
-The thing I'd
like to accomplish
is at least change the mind of
one child about healthy eating
and know that, hey, there is
other alternatives rather than
fast food.
-I want to create
something that can sustain
itself, that can be
passed on, something
that will last beyond me.
-We definitely have the power,
the sources, the intelligence.
So what's stopping us?
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
CHARLIE: So one of
the big audiences here
is parents at Google.
And I think that there's a lot
of confusion around when you're
just at the grocery store,
whether you're at Whole Foods,
or like another
market, or what not,
like what do these
terms even mean,
and how do I even make
sure that what I'm buying
is actually accomplishing
the goal of helping
my kid eat healthy.
So on that note, do you have
any kind of, first of all,
one thing that you
would advise parents
to do to better educate
themselves so that they know
what to feed their kids
and how to kind of sort
through the terminologies
and kind of the confusion
around the market?
And then second of all, I
guess, how do you enforce that
especially in the
Bay Area, where not
every kid has access to
a backyard or a garden
to play with?
CURT ELLIS: Awesome.
Do you want to take that?
SARAH TING: Sure.
My first thought when you
were asking that question is I
think for any family, if you're
able to, getting into a kitchen
and cooking together.
I think about memories that
I have growing up with food.
And it was those
tactile moments of being
able to touch the food
that you're making,
or that you're
just about to eat,
and getting in the kitchen
with any sort of fresh produce
and making a meal out of
it is a really fun thing
for kids to do, and to
learn to love maybe foods
that they think that
are gross to begin with.
Also, if you have the ability,
maybe just to have a pot, not
even the whole garden,
but just a singular pot
to plant a few seeds--
I remember growing up,
my mom would grow just
one pot of tomatoes.
And I hated tomatoes
at the time.
But every summer, she would
plant this one pot of tomatoes.
And every summer she made
me try a cherry tomato.
And I grew, over the years,
to love cherry tomatoes,
not necessarily because I
naturally had an inclination
to love them, but
because I had that memory
of picking a sun kissed
cherry tomato from the vine
with my mother.
And so creating those memories,
I think, is also really key.
CURT ELLIS: Love it.
Yeah, a quick guide is
Michael Pollan's "Food Rules".
I don't really like the
idea of having food rules
that much, I think.
But those rules are
actually really simple.
It's just about eating real,
food mostly plants, and not
too much.
ALEX GARCIA: Have you guys
run into any roadblocks
with the schools?
Like when I was kind
of looking into it,
one thing that I think about
is I know a lot of schools
have contracts
with big companies.
Is that something
that you've seen?
CURT ELLIS: Yeah, I mean the
roadblocks are always there.
And they're always
really interesting.
I think what I love
about the Food Corps
model is we have
people like Sarah who
are very disarming in a
conversation with a food
service director,
because she's not
a hired gun outside
consultant there to tell
you're doing something wrong.
And she's not a finger
wagging upset parent.
She's there as a young
person who is devoting a year
or more of her life
to service to help.
And I have a colleague
who served in Food Corps'
first class but is now on
the national staff with us
who told me about how,
during the first six
months of his service
in northern Michigan,
every single day he put on
his hair net and his beard,
and he went into the back
of the school kitchen,
and he said how can
I help you today.
And it took six months
of doing that before he
knew it was safe to say, hey,
so I've got an idea for how
you could help me.
There's local asparagus,
local cherries,
a bunch of local farmers
here in northern Michigan
who are eager to
start selling to us.
How would you feel
about piloting that?
How would you feel about
starting this work together?
And the pace of change
he was able to achieve
by being an ally to
a food service worker
who has a ton of other
responsibilities on their plate
was really, really
pretty fantastic.
SPEAKER 1: So certainly
in the Bay Area,
I imagine it's not that hard to
get parents or schools on board
with the idea of healthy eating.
But what's it like
in other markets?
I understand you guys have
members all over the country.
What's it like in
other markets where
healthy eating and
local food isn't
as prevalent of a conversation
topic as it is out here?
CURT ELLIS: I think
one of the things Sarah
said is really right
and really important,
which is every culture has
a version of healthy food.
And your job is to kind of
unearth that and help bring it
to life.
Our sense is there's a real risk
of an organization like Food
Corps kind of airdropping
kale around the country
and thinking we've done
good, when I think actually
that risk's doing a lot of harm.
So for us, it's about
finding the ways to make
our work relevant to the
food culture of Jackson,
Mississippi, not imagining that
the food culture of Jackson,
Mississippi should look
exactly like the food
culture of Oakland--
super different places.
I think it's been really
interesting to see how,
in a number of places, what is
most resonant about the work
Food Corps does is that it's
about teaching old skills.
It's about teaching kids to grow
a garden, and to cook a meal,
and to be self-sufficient in
ways that are really understood
by members of an
older generation,
or members of the older
parts of American culture.
So we tap into that a lot.
In our work in
Montana, we've been
really successful with
grass fed beef to school
and supporting some really cool
efforts to make that transition
start to happen there.
It's because the families in the
school are ranchers themselves
and are excited
to have the chance
to sell beef that they've
raised on the range in Montana
straight into
their kid's school,
and to be able to show up with
a horse, and show up with a cow,
and say, look, you know this
is what farming is like.
So we're very careful to
remain above the partisan fray
and above the kind of
politicization of food,
because food is meant to
be personal and cultural.
And our job is to kind of
help unlock that in a way
that is good for kids.
CHARLIE: We have schools.
We have the home.
I think also a lot of our
relationship with food
comes from restaurants
that we frequent.
What do you see is the role of
restaurants in promoting this?
And what do you think that,
whether you're a parent or just
somebody who loves
food-- what can
you do to kind of
send the signal
that the restaurants
out there in our area
should take part
in this mission?
CURT ELLIS: Yeah, I mean I
think it's hugely important,
especially as our food
habits have shifted more
towards eating out.
We've got a real role
for restaurants to play.
And you can see it happen quite
easily at high end restaurants
where the farm to table
thing has really gone off
the charts in terms of being
celebrated and fetishized maybe
a little too far in some ways.
I'm most excited to
be seeing it happening
at restaurants that are down
the street from our cornfield
in Iowa.
I'm really excited about
the work Panera is doing up
their supply chain
to make sure they're
sourcing food from
responsible places,
and that they're not using
additives that they could use
and that a lot of other
companies have used.
That stuff is really important.
It makes a huge difference.
So beginning to
push as a consumer,
to show that you care
about those things,
is really important.
One of the challenges
Chipotle faces
is that, for all of their
efforts to improve the supply
chain, every time they
do market research
it seems to come back that
the consumers aren't actually
going there because they've
improved their supply chain.
And those of us who do
go there because they've
improved their supply
chain, I think,
have a real responsibility
to stand up and say, hey,
I'm here because you are more
responsible than other parties
about where you source
the food you're serving.
So for a while I was carrying
around these really annoying
business cards in my wallet that
explained I did not order meat
at this restaurant,
because your meat did not
come from a sustainable source.
I would encourage you to check
out the following resources
to improve your supply chains.
It was a little less
snarky than that.
But the point was the same.
I've stopped doing that, just
because it was too weird.
But I think on some level
that is the message we all
need to be communicating
is, I'm making
choices for whether I
come to your restaurant,
and I'm making
choices then for what
I order at your restaurant
through a lens of health,
and sustainability, and
social justice, and values
that I care about.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So it definitely
makes sense why you'd
start with kids in schools, but
I'd imagine in high poverty,
inner city areas
decisions from parents
is still something
that'd be really hard
to change, especially
from a price point
perspective and what not.
So I'm curious what
you guys are seeing
in terms of changes
and challenges,
as well as what
maybe you see ahead
for you guys in
terms of that arena?
CURT ELLIS: Do you want
to take a first crack?
SARAH TING: Yeah,
I think absolutely.
I mean, these are large scale
problems that we're talking
about, as Curt was outlining.
These are big, national,
international scale issues.
And so the solutions that we
have to come at the problem
with have to be big.
But we can do it on a
smaller scale in school food,
because for a lot of inner
city, low income areas,
school food is one of the
primary places where kids get
their nourishment for the day.
That's an incredibly impactful
program, potentially, for kids.
So when you're looking at
the majority of your calories
coming from school food, if
we can shift the food products
there for kids, we can
potentially change the exposure
that kids have to
healthier fresh foods,
connect them-- reconnect them--
to their personal, cultural
relationship to food, and just
have the bottom line better
nourishment so kids
can focus in school
and realize their potential.
And those are really big things.
So I think never
under estimating
the potential of a school
lunch or school breakfast
is a way to start.
But in terms of
the larger cultural
and political economic
forces, it's a big challenge.
But I think acknowledging
that it is a bigger problem,
and then coming to the parents,
and school administrators,
and the Nutrition Services
repairmen with that attitude
of saying we know this is
bigger than you all, this is not
something any one
person can carry,
but why don't we collaborate
and collectively, together,
work on some solutions-- I
think that's a way that we
can get some real work done.
CURT ELLIS: Yeah, and in terms
of where Food Corps is headed
from here, we have had a
really amazing first five
years of running this program.
And we've grown by
leaps and bounds.
We went from a start-up that
nobody had heard, didn't exist,
to a $2 million, $4 million,
$6 million, $9 million budget.
We're heading
towards a $12 million
budget for the year
that's beginning now.
We have an amazing national
staff team of 35 folks
and then 215 Corps members in
the field across the country.
And I've talked a
fair amount today
about our kind of direct
program in schools,
because that's really the
foundation on which all
of Food Corps'
aspirations are built.
But the rest of
those aspirations
are really real and
important for us.
The first is, if you
take that direct program,
and you get it strong
enough in enough places,
you can really prove the impact
of having healthy school food
environments for
kids in a way that
will be meaningful
for ultimately driving
systemic change up
here that starts
to reach towards the
100,000 school scale
at which this problem exists.
So you start with the
refining our program
to really get the impact we're
all trying to drive towards,
as measured by meaningful shifts
in kids' consumption of fruits
and vegetables.
We're doing a big study with
Columbia University research
partners right now where they're
testing school food consumption
levels around fruits and
vegetables in particular
in a bunch of different
Food Corps schools
across eight states to help
build that evidence base.
So we can scale that program
up and need to, not only
in the places we already
work, but get to critical mass
in places that are particularly
important to really
be operating at a meaningful
level across a school district.
And then, on top of that
foundation of direct impact,
we have amazing
people like Sarah
who are going on to lifelong
careers in the fields of food,
and health, and equity that
have incredible potential
to keep shaping this work
for the next generation.
So already the food
service director
for all of Fayetteville,
Arkansas, that's
a Food Corps alum who they
loved, and created a job for,
and brought back, and then
promoted to Food Service
Director.
Here in California, we have
senior food service folks
in Monterey and North
Monterey Unified.
So getting our alums on those
paths makes a huge difference.
Second, what could we
be doing to harness
the network of
other organizations
across the country that are
doing this work in partnership
with Food Corps in
other ways on their own?
How can we get them using
a consistent framework,
speaking with a common voice,
leveraging shared data?
And then ultimately,
together, how can we
take the direct impact and use
those two networks to amplify
it to drive systemic change
that's around policy shifts
and culture shifts that really
help make healthy school food
environments the norm
rather than the exception?
CHARLIE: This point
we are out of time.
But I wanted to thank
Curt and Sarah again
for bringing great insight and
experience to a problem that
is very important to our
generation and future
generations as well.
Thank you again, and I'd like to
have another round of applause
for Curt and Sarah.
[APPLAUSE]